mirela teruya calls it her dream job for
12 years she's worked in a state-run
home for the aging in Sarajevo and she
loves it even though there are far too
few staff to take care of the 400
residents mirela regularly works over 11
hours a day she's highly qualified but
the job pays just 500 euros a month
that's it you have to finish nursing
school
yeah that's not easy and the training
program because when you're through with
the classes you still have a year-long
internship and then because the training
program they go through is so rigorous
nursing staff from Bosnia are also
sought after in other countries
mirela says some colleagues work in
Germany but now a scandal has tarnished
the country's reputation for nursing
excellence
investigative journalist Ezra O'Mara
which discovered that several schools in
Bosnia have sold diplomas to people with
no training at all she uncovered the
fraud by posing as an interested client
there was some younger brighter with
fauna right here where we're sitting now
now I'll totally different 2500 Bosnian
my graduation certificate organized
everything documented see it took
exactly is for me to get a diploma first
telephones got palsy but then I never
set foot in the school let alone taking
exams of yard by Avila towards quarry
for lager look I faced the worst on a
Maravich and her editorial department
secretly filmed her interactions with
the fraudsters and confronted him when
he gave her the Diploma the employee in
the area of Public Health refused to
name any backers and so far he hasn't
lost his job
news like that makes Marilla angry she
knows better than anyone how even
experienced nurses can make a mistake
that potentially fatal consequences
untrained staff who brought their
diplomas could cause tremendous harm
that's playing with people's lives this
is a job with a huge responsibility for
someone's life which I could never do
that
someone do something Maravich and her
colleagues discovered the diploma she
bought wasn't just a cheap copy of a
real one
it included certificates and
documentation backing it up it says a
Maravich trained at a nursing school for
two years and there were even records of
grades she supposedly got in courses a
foreign employer would never have been
able to determine it wasn't authentic
much give last the Nationals eat
I'm afraid the German authorities are
going to hit the wall because the wall
of organized crime and
bosnia-herzegovina clearly now is Iran
the sistine was me herzegovinian if the
Germans want to verify the influence was
the issue people that come to German
authorities much it probably messed up
what's not Scott Hairston Whatcom
lastima that be pretty until you
wouldn't a deployment a loss because the
Bosnian Authority is a criminal system
only me now the scandal is a disaster
for nursing schools that play by the
rules the reputation for good work they
worked hard to achieve is being ruined
by corrupt competitors we starting in
the same thing into we were just
attacked for badness doesn't make sense
the police informed the state
prosecutor's office in San Diego about
the case four months ago so far it
hasn't reacted politicians are demanding
diplomas be examined for authenticity
not an investigation into the schools
that issued them illegally morality Elia
says she's never considered taking a
more lucrative position abroad but for
other graduates of Bosnia nursing
schools who dream of a job in Western
Europe the fraud has made landing one a
much tougher proposition